we watch a lot of tarantino we watch a
lot of spielberg so what happens is that
people try to copy or aaron sorkin like
as a writer
what was your strategy for becoming a
director was it just an idea in your
head or you had a very specific plan as
you did when you said i want to dance
with michael jackson
yeah i um
i learned this actually from the
corporate world um creating smart goals
i've heard that that term before smart
no i like it specific measurable
actionable realistic and time-bound okay
so basically what that means is that you
know you have this really big goal at
the end of the of the rainbow but in
order to get there you need small little
goals to get there
and so for me
what that look like is okay i need if i
want to be a director i need to learn
how to direct
but nobody's going to hire you fresh out
of college as a director so it's
probably good if i learn how to write
so let me know how to write
and then from the writing
i'll use my writing skills to direct
what i wrote
now i need something that's going to be
a really good calling card something
that
uh i need a short film
that nobody else could be able to you
know would be able to make other than me
oh i'm a core a choreographer so why
don't i make something that actually is
kind of like hamilton
but
you know i'm doing it you know in this
college campus here so if they had
access to red cameras
um the really cool thing about the group
that was i was uh in class with there's
about 50 of us
and the way they would work is the
teacher great teacher amazing guy
um charlie
charlie uh charles meyers
charlie myers um
he now chooses that uh chapman but uh at
the time that saddleback so the way it
works is
anybody that wants to direct something
you go to the front of the class and you
pitch your idea and then the people will
vote with their feet
if you can crew up based upon your idea
then you can get your your project made
so i went up there and explained what i
want to do
and initially
it was
nothing about
the musical it was some other you know
thing
that
it wasn't me and so my teacher was like
hey
you spent all this time choreographing
why don't you do something that actually
showcases your skills and i'm like you
know what you're right
so then on the spot i made up an idea
for this short film and everyone in the
class was like i want in on that
i had no idea how i was going to make it
but i went ahead and pitched it and it's
kind of ambitious i mean it takes it's a
musical it's a 14-minute musical
um
takes place over three different time
periods
the end of slavery
the end of segregation of the 1960s and
when obama gets elected and so we
literally go through three different
time periods
and it's going to highlight this man
named isaac who's looking for work in
america and it shows how america changes
over time but
the issues that he was dealing with as a
slave and as a man of the 1960s and in
the 1980s i'm sorry when obama gets
elected he was still dealing with
and we had three songs original music we
had choreography
and that was crazy but we did it
and so the plan was to be a director and
i got a chance to direct my short film
because i took those small steps by
learning how to write learning how to
direct learning grips learning how to
edit movies
so i learned all this while i was in
school and that helped me to get to that
point of making the short film now for
anybody that's out there that is
looking to get representation as a
director your short film is your
business card
so you want to make it as distinctive as
distinctive and as unique as you can
put yourself into it because nobody else
can make the movie that i wrote
because you had to have that background
in order to do what i just did and so as
a result of that that's what got me my
managers and then that's what got me my
agent and that's what got me the job you
know to to write the christmas movie
so i would say if anybody is looking to
to you know give representation
yeah write something that is that is um
close to you intimate to you
that only you could write
uh telling it from a story
from only a place that you could write
from and that's what will help to make
you different than any other director
out there and that's why people will
actually gravitate towards you and what
was the name of the short film
reparations okay and you made that a
saddleback yeah community college wow
and if if anybody will have the link
below this but i mean you also have a
beautiful use of like color in all of
your projects i notice you do have an
interesting like palette that you work
with and when people saw that
what do they tell you
did they tell you keep going you should
submit this you should use this as your
business card yeah so
when i made it
i you know put into film festivals it
did very well
and then
shortly after that i is when i got my
manager
uh my managers
after that um
so
we kind of it kind of just
snowballed from one thing to the next so
you said managers yes
managers um
because they are a team they work
together so you get one to get the other
they both own the company they work
together and everything it's kind of a
nice situation because it's a black
woman and a caucasian male
so it's great because i get two
different perspectives because they have
two different backgrounds from two
different unique places and so when i
write my projects a lot of my projects
actually have female leads
i don't know why that is just the way it
is
um it could be part of it could be
business-wise i mean that's what a lot
of people are looking for these days
so it's nice to get notes from her
because she's coming at it from that
point of view and then he's coming at it
from a different point of view and so
it's when i get my notes i'm getting
this full well-rounded like almost
four-quadrant kind of thing in regard in
regards to you know what is going to
work what's how the scene is going to
work or what's going to sell so i like
that i have two managers i just you know
the company i'm with they just happen to
have two managers so i was lucky enough
to have them
very cool it's like having two twin
sisters yeah that's true
very good what stops most people from
finding an agent or manager what stops
most people from from uh finding an
agent or a manager
i think
the biggest thing
well i guess it just depends on what
we're talking about here we're talking
about a writer or we're talking about a
director i can give you definitely
from the director's point of view
um
it's hard because because i do both
like to me it's not like i i got one
as a writer one as a director i'm like
because i'm a package deal
i got them both but
you know the thing is going back to the
idea of
having a piece of work whether it's
writing or directing
that is unique to you
that's what it is it's like because of
the fact that we we watch a lot of
tarantino we watch a lot of spielberg so
what happens is that people try to copy
or aaron sorkin like as a writer we try
to copy that person's work and so when
we give these samples of our work it's
not original
it feels like a knockoff of these other
people
so what's what what a lot of managers
are looking for they're looking for
people that have unique voices it's
hollywood everything is packaged
so great
so here's my example
when they send my short film
now that i have a real they see my my my
my reel of my work
of all the different tv shows and movies
there's a story behind who courtney is
and your managers your agents are going
to want to
have something that's able to tell the
story so in my story you know i'm this
kid from compton i choreographed from
michael jackson you know i have a dance
background you know musicals i mean i'm
a writer director like that's a nice
story that you can sell to networks and
networks want stories
your manager is the same way they need
to find a way to make you feel different
than all these other people that are out
there there's so many writers there's so
many directors out there so
what what's keeping a lot of people from
getting a manager
or an agent
is the fact that that they haven't
figured out what their story is
and
and the project that they're writing or
the project that they've directed as a
short film
is not
different enough to separate
from other people that are doing
something similar
some if if they were to write something
that's specific to them
you know that would be a huge help
because now i can i can tell that story
you know
he or she came from
you know mexico he or she you know came
from a strong catholic background or
whatever whatever the situation is in
their own personal experience that's
what's going to make you easier to sell
to a manager
sure do you think a lot of people start
looking for an hdr manager and they
don't have a lot of life experience
and maybe that
i mean maybe that doesn't factor i don't
know yeah i think i think some people
who are looking for managers or agents
don't have life experiences um
and you know that means you need to go
out and experience life but
even that being the case like if you're
19 18 you don't have a lot of life
experience but you have a family you
have you have a legacy within your
family that you can
that you can kind of draw from
every single one of us have something
really unique and different about our
families and the way we grew up that we
can draw from and sometimes you kind of
have to put a light on that
and folks don't know how to do that
they know how to write they know a
structure of a script but they don't
know how to tell their own story and
that's the issue until you're able to do
that you're not different than any of
these other writers and if that be the
case then there's no way that they're
going to be able to market you and make
money off of you as a writer without
something that's special unique about
yourself
did you realize that about yourself
at an early age that there was something
unique or did it take time
yeah i never even thought about
me being unique or different i i didn't
think about that at all and i the only
time i started thinking about that was
when i started writing and directing
because i was saying to myself why would
a person hire a 40 year old writer a 40
year old director what is different
about me what do i offer that a lot of
other people don't have and that's
another reason why i wanted to learn how
to write was because
as i mentioned there are some really
amazing directors
who are former choreographers
so
you know whether it's um
the other people that i mentioned before
the one thing that they can do that i
can do is they can't write
and i knew i needed to have something
different like why would you hire me
over kenny ortega keno ortega has a lot
you know he did high school musical like
he's huge
so what what is what what do i have that
kenny doesn't have oh i can write
and i can direct so
again i'm trying to find again that
probably is the competitiveness in me
trying to find a way to separate myself
from these other gentlemen who i look up
to who i love their work but it's like
no i i can do something that they can't
do so when you hire me you're getting
this package deal plus i can choreograph
plus i've choreographed for the biggest
people in the world so um yeah i needed
something that you know with my own
story my own spin why
you think two i mean not to get too
personal forgive me but you were a young
father
and the pressures that put on you yeah
and to balance all of this i i'm not a
parent so i don't know what that's like
but i would imagine that's
really tough so you're doing all of this
and you're a parent yeah that's a very
good point the fact that i was married
at a young age the fact that i was a
young father you know
and i needed to
do what i needed to do to take care of
my family in a legal way um
that definitely gave me some life
experience that i could draw from so
even if i was and here's the thing
though it's like even at the age of 20 i
was still dancing i wasn't even thinking
about writing or directing but let's say
i had i had that that that
that goal
like man it would have been amazing to
be able to write back then because i was
coming from a different point of view
you're right the idea of
living life
for the good and for the bad the wins
and the losses all of that
is nice rich information that you can
use and you can put into your your
scripts with characters that have lived
life that's one thing that's it's tough
when you're 18 19 20 years old you
haven't lived life so the characters
that you're right i mean it was very
common
and it's still common today when when uh
people that around that age write
a movie a short film a lot of the movies
and short films if you're 18 19 years of
age is about people that are smoking
weed and are high
because that's that that's the reality
that's their life
but it's like
okay we've seen that before like this
what's special about that
nothing and that's why
and that's why you have to
like if you are that young in your
writing and directing look at
look at life through other lenses
you know look at your family look at
your think about your uncle or your
auntie what they've gone through and you
can pull from that even if you haven't
experienced it yourself um there's
people that you can talk to and draw
experiences from and i think even within
your own family that that's possible
even if you don't have a lot of life
experiences yourself but yeah the fact
that i was a young kid
and had a family that helped me a big
time regarding life experiences